collège visitation la berrière cours de
géographie
aujourd'hui le climat les faire
référence à la base de cet exposé le
syllabus de géographie notions
théoriques première édition page 46
ainsi que les fiches techniques 22 et 24
qui vous sont distribués au cours
si vous ne faites pas partie des élèves
du collège hésitation à bernières vous
pouvez toujours me contacter avec la par
l'adresse mail qui est affiché à l'écran
et je me ferai un plaisir de vous
envoyer les documents haddock
vous pouvez consultez également le site
du court le blu geo
commençons par une définition si vous le
voulez bien le climat et l'ensemble des
caractéristiques de l'atmosphère et
leurs variations on a lieu donné sur une
longue période
nous allons voir les différentes
caractéristiques de l'atmosphère au
cours de cette vidéo
mais ici j'aimerais insister sur le fait
que le climat et reprend tous les
phénomènes sur une longue période
on observe des changements qui se font
sur des dizaines d'années généralement
se base sur des moyennes de 30 ans ce
qui oppose le climat à la météo la météo
en fait va observer également des
mouvements de l'atmosphère mais sur une
très courte période
c'est ce qui distingue le climat de la
météo l'atmosphère du grec
atmos la vapeur et se ferra la sphère
est en fait la couche d'air qui entoure
la terre
nous voyons ici sur la représentation
graphique de droite que l'atmosphère est
composé de plusieurs couches dont la
première est la troposphère la
troposphère et la première couche de
l'atmosphère on va retrouver des gaz en
grande quantité comme le co2 l'oxygène
ou la zot et au sein de cette
troposphère nous allons observer la
plupart des phénomènes climatiques et
météorologiques
il n'y a pas 36 caractéristiques de
l'atmosphère
les principales caractéristiques
auxquelles on va s'attarder
c'est les températures et les
précipitations
c'est à dire la pluie la neige et la
grêle on pourrait également prendre en
compte la nébulosité c'est à dire le
nombre de nuages qui a dans le ciel pour
un endroit où l'ensoleillement le nombre
d'heures où le soleil brille
effectivement mais ces facteurs sont
vraiment secondaires par rapport aux
températures et aux précipitations qui
sont vraiment la clé de compréhension de
tout phénomène climatique
les températures sont mesurés en degrés
celsius
elles le sont à différents endroits on
mesure jour après jour mois après mois
année après année et on peut établir de
cette manière des moyennes on va établir
par exemple les moyennes annuelles en
prenant en compte par exemple 30 années
de suite
vous voyez ici le la carte qui est
proposée par l'irm l'institut royal de
météorologie belge a pris une période de
référence de 1981 à 2010 c'est vraiment
une observation sur le long terme et on
va constater que certaines régions ont
les mêmes températures moyennes
annuelles
on va les regrouper au sein d'une même
catégorie et vous voyez qu ici sur la
carte par exemple toutes les zones en
rouge ont une température moyenne
annuelle comprise entre 10,5 et 11
degrés c'est limite
on va les appeler des iso terme c'est à
dire que ce sont des lignes sur
lesquelles tous les points qui constitue
la ligne ont la même température moyenne
iso mêmes termes température une fois
que je connais la température des lieux
je peux calculer des amplitudes
thermiques
je vais par exemple comme s'est proposé
ici dans la formule calcul et
l'amplitude thermique pour une année
en fait il s'agit des températures les
plus froides
comparé aux températures les plus
chaudes et ça va me donner une
différence qui va me permettre de
mesurer et de comparer les différents
écarts de température entre différentes
régions
donc pour calculer la température
amplitudes thermiques d'une année pour
un lieu je vais prendre la température
moyenne du mois le plus chaud et je vais
la soustraire par exemple par la
température moyenne du mois le plus
froid
les précipitations sont mesurés en
millimètres et un millimètre représente
une quantité d'un litre d'eau tombée sur
un mètre carré les précipitations c'est
plutôt qui vient sous différentes formes
de l'atmosphère à savoir la pluie la
neige ou la grêle
contrairement aux températures où on
additionne pas les différentes
températures jour après jour où on fait
directement une moyenne les
précipitations sont additionnés donc on
va comparer des totaux de précipitation
et ensuite on fera seulement la moyenne
sur base de cette auto donc on voit sur
la carte qui est proposé ici encore une
fois par l'irm pour une période allant
de 1981 à 2010 on voit que les régions
du sud du pays sont beaucoup plus
touchés par les précipitations
puisqu'on aura des valeurs allant
jusqu'à 1400 mm par an en moyenne
alors que d'autres régions sont à moitié
moins de précipitation c'est à dire 700
mm par an en moyenne
on pourra calculé sur base de ces
précipitations du bilan hydrique le
bilan hydrique en fait est ce qu'il
tombe plus d'eau
est ce que le territoire du lieu choisi
reçoit plus d'eau qu'il ne perde au
commente à ce qu'on perde luz est
essentiellement par évaporation
donc si je soustrais l'évaporation des
précipitations j'obtiens le bilan
hydrique
si je perds plus d'eau par l'évaporation
que je n'en reçois ma région est située
dans une zone aride l'aridité c'est un
bilan hydrique négatif en fait
les variations des températures et des
précipitations pour un mât lui-même lieu
va me permettre de classer ce lieu dans
un climat mais je pourrais tout d'abord
aussi voir ce qu'il y à une saison sèche
en fait une saison sèche d'une période
où il va faire relativement chaud et où
il y aura très peu de précipitations
alors pour déterminer si une région
connaît une saison sèche je vais prendre
le total des précipitations mensuelles
de cette région et je vais les comparer
aux température mensuelle moyenne fois
deux pour le même mois évidemment et si
la valeur que j'ai obtenus pour mes
précipitations est inférieur aux
températures mensuelles x 2 j'ai une
saison sèche nous pourrons retrouver à
la fois les précipitations et les
températures sur ce qu'on appelle un
diagramme ombreux thermique
le diagramme ombreux thermique va
reprendre deux éléments les
précipitations sous forme de bâtonnets
avec les valeurs qui sont indiqués en
ordonner à gauche et les températures
sous forme d'une courbe avec les valeurs
qui sont mentionnés à droite du
graphique est toujours en ordonnée alors
vous pouvez remarquer que ces valeurs
sont moitié moins importantes du côté
des températures que du côté des
précipitations
si je prends la valeur des températures
et je fais fois du j'obtiens au même
niveau les précipitations
c'est ce qui va me permettre de
directement voir visuellement s'il ya
une saison sèche
si le bâtonnet des précipitations passe
en dessous de la courbe de température
c'est qu'il ya une saison sèche
donc je vois ici que pour pékin j'ai
deux saisons sèches à savoir celle ci
et celle ci est encore celle ci l'est
pas et forcément évidente
je peux voir également sur certains
diagramme directement les valeurs mais
ça c'est pas forcément toujours le cas
vous avez ici aussi au niveau annuel les
totaux annuels
et ce qui est très important pour
pouvoir localiser après ces différents
station météo ou les relevés sont fait
quand même pour des périodes assez
importante voit ici c 1961 et mieux son
nom est toujours une trentaine d'années
j'ai la latitude la longitude est
également l'altitude puisqu'on verra
plus tard que l'altitude a un rôle
considérable sur la définition du climat
d'une région une fois les différentes
données relatives aux températures et
aux précipitations collecter et comparer
on va pouvoir définir différents climats
pour les lieux qu'ils auront les mêmes
variations de températures et de
précipitations selon les mois on va
classer ces différents climats et la
classification qui généralement retenue
par la communauté scientifique et celle
du biologiste que penn qui va être
précisé par son collègue geiger un peu
plus tard et qui débouche sur cinq
grandes familles de climat ils sont tous
désignés par une lettre allant de a à e
à étant les climats les plus chauds et
eux les climats les plus froids on aura
tout d'abord les climats tropicaux les
climats a qui sont représentés sous
cette carte de l'université de melbourne
dans les couleurs bleu nous aurons
ensuite les climat sec en b représenté
dans des couleurs un peu plus chaud ici
ensuite les climats tempérés
on sait
rendez les climats continentaux
et eux les climat polaire et de toundra
les climat polaire les plus froids voilà
évidemment on peut voir que les climats
les plus froids sont situés vers les
pôles zone qui reçoivent le moins de
chaleur du soleil et les régions
tropicales sont situés plutôt autour de
l'équateur dans la zone inter-tropicale
voilà cette vidéo est terminée pour les
élèves du collège d'hésitation la
berlière n'oubliez pas de répondre petit
questionnaire et les autres visionneur
de cette vidéo peuvent éventuellement
poser leurs questions sur youtube
à bientôt au revoir